la femme d'un fleuron de l'énergie à la
française aujourd'hui la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim est mise à
l'arrêt longtemps réclamée par des
associations redouté par les salariés
cette fermeture a agité les débats y
compris sur le site théâtre de
manifestations en 1977 duff mois avant
la mise en service alsaciens et
allemands expriment déjà leur crainte
par rapport à l'activité nucléaire
depuis 25 jours en tout cas cette
personne font une grève de la faim dans
un village du haut rhin rogan en 1981 en
trois ans d'activité fessenheim cumule
plusieurs dysfonctionnements aucune
catastrophe à déplorer mais les
écologistes allemands et alsaciens
viennent de protester à vélo devant le
cordon de gendarmes mobiles les
écologies s'installait et bloquer tout
passage entre l'allemagne et la france
en 2007 alors que fait ce même prépare
cette trente ans les associations
dénoncent les failles de sécurité une
crainte d'attaqués terroristes car la
piscine de désactivation de combustible
est exposée avec des arbres pas très
compliqué même pas trop performant
perforantes
on peut créer la catastrophe de cette
façon là
la contestation des associations mais
aussi des politiques
en 2011 plusieurs municipalités
alsacienne réclament l'arrêt de la
centrale en 2012 françois hollande alors
président de la république promet la
fermeture forcément pour les salariés
c'est un coup dur au travail et puis on
va voir ce qui va se passer je suis un
peu dans le doute et dans la tente la
main quand on vient ici on comprend pas
pourquoi il veut absolument la ferme et
elle est peut-être la plus vieille on a
fait des rénovations de sur la fée
entretien car la commune de fessenheim
est aussi un bassin économique autour de
lusine malgré tout en 2016 edf annonce
la fermeture de la centrale pour 2018
et c'est au tour des salariés de
manifester devant le siège d'edf à paris
un sacrifice de plus de 2000 emplois
directs et indirects
c'est une escroquerie intellectuelle de
faire croire à la population locale aux
salariés locale qu'il ya des solutions
rapides de reclassement fermer en 2020
la doyenne des centrales nucléaires aura
produit pendant quarante deux ans son
démantèlement devrait débuter en 2025
[Musique]